[Applause]
hi phoebe hi how are you
[Music]
wonderful thank you so much for doing
this show
you are so well loved and respected
and there are so many incredible things
that you're doing i'm actually worried
about how we're going to get to them all
but we're going to okay
but i'm going to start off with your
boyfriend
who yes you post about you're so lovely
and when i look at you guys on instagram
i'm like huh
there is so much here and so much
romance and fun
it makes me want to jump into a
relationship and you guys have been
together
three years yeah three years uh-huh well
yeah it's been great i thank you for
sprinkling the romance
on social media and you guys talk about
stuff that's going on in the world
what do you think a good recipe for
talking about politics and comedy is
yeah i mean it's always tricky because
you don't want to preach right like you
want to make people feel like they're
invited into the conversation so i
always try to start with
focusing on myself and making fun of
myself and then opening up but i think
right now it's really
we need to have a lot of conversations i
think what's so great about my boyfriend
a lot of my friends is that we're able
to sort of find the
moments of humor within this sort of
intensity that's going on right now and
just
making it a safe space i think that's
the biggest thing is that people get
defensive when they feel like they're
being attacked so it's like no we're
just
being open and we want to express ideas
to try and come up with a solution
that's exactly what i want to be able to
do with this show
is embrace everybody's differences talk
about them or not talk about them but
definitely lean in on the similarities
and how to have
conversations whatever they may be
without righteousness because everybody
turns away from that
it's like the human condition when
somebody you know comes at you
you recoil yeah and i think it's a lot
of just sort of being like hey i've made
mistakes too i've messed up too i think
a lot of times people
when they get new information now they
act as though they've always had
information as opposed to being like
we're all learning at different
paces we're all starting at different
points and so
make sure that like yes we're learning
and to be inclusive as opposed to
i know all the information and why don't
you because then it's like well no one's
perfect you know
and you're writing a book where it's
sort of like diaries of quarantine
yeah yeah it's called six feet apart and
it's sort of talking about
you know i think we all sort of thought
oh we'd be quarantining for you know two
weeks and here we are
months and months later and so i'm
writing about things like
quarantining with my boyfriend which is
amazing but we're also
sort of you know we're farting all the
time now so we're kind of like weird
things that you do if you're
single or you have time apart we're just
always together so the body functions
just happen when they
happen and then you know write about
like performative allyship
and you know working in stand-up comedy
and so i think it's going to be another
essay collection it's really funny but
also has you know some stuff to say so
i'm really excited about it and
i'm super pumped about this imprint
because i remember
my first book plume was the only
publisher that wanted like so many
places
you know turned me down and said i was
too niche or like oh
a essay collection written by a black
woman won't sell like i was really just
told that
i had no place in the industry to now be
five years later and have this imprint
i'm just kind of over the moon and sort
of like oh okay things are
you know slowly changing which is
exciting and you felt that it was
important
to shine a light to give a platform for
voices that weren't being
heard otherwise yeah because i just
never wanted
anyone to go through what i went through
because it is really demoralizing you
put
you know this work together that you're
so excited about and you want to share
with people and then publishers are like
no you're not good enough no your voice
isn't valid
and i was like oh my god i don't want
that to happen anyone else so with this
imprint i want to be really open and
we're looking for a literary fiction
nonfiction essay collections and like
just if you have a voice and you have a
story that you want to share we want to
hear it
i am so inspired i so love that
and it's so incentivizing for people to
hear that because
if other people want to lift others up
first of all you don't go down when you
lift others up you go right with them
and i so believe that and then what
you're doing for others
is just a good incentivization for
others
to do that for others it goes on and on
and on it's a domino effect of
positivity
yes oh that was a great way i like that
domino effect of positivity
oh yeah